varios pacientes infectados por el virus
del ébola fueron detectados en campana
la capital holandesa el pasado mes de
octubre desde entonces los centros de
salud han estado en alerta como este en
los suburbios de la ciudad el doctor
mujeres acaba de recibir el primer caso
sospechoso del día es el que ha sido
aislado este adolescente tiene varios
síntomas del virus mortal el médico
permanece atento en tres meses más de 50
ondeses sucumbieron en la enfermedad
entre ellos cinco trabajadores
sanitarios elevó la no es fácil de
manejar todos nosotros estamos en riesgo
las personas a las que tratamos también
están en riesgo cuando vemos que es
positivo aislamos a la familia en algún
sitio y les damos unos días para ver si
desarrollan los síntomas el médico debe
protegerse con este atuendo esencial
para recoger una muestra de sangre los
resultados no llegarán hasta dentro de
varias horas este centro de salud No
tiene un espacio dedicado a la
enfermedad el paciente tiene que
quedarse en el patio este médico está
solo para hacer frente a la emergencia
pero como médico de primera línea hago
lo que puedo pero si no no puedo
permitir me rindo como me estoy jugando
la vida también necesito que me apoyen
la mayoría de la gente se aleja de esta
situación y morirá más gente el sistema
sanitario de uganda es frágil
especialmente en campana una ciudad de 4
millones de habitantes estos pacientes
desconfían de la epidemia cuando venimos
aquí nos dan instrucciones que tenemos
que obedecer si ves a un paciente
demasiado cerca de ti tienes que
distanciarte y esperar para ocupar su
lugar no se han detectado nuevas
infecciones desde hace una semana a
pesar de la falta de recursos el país
parece estar ganando la batalla pero
para la ong médicos Sin fronteras la
situación sigue siendo preocupante hay
muchos casos de contacto es gente que
puede enfermar y no sabemos exactamente
dónde están y cómo se encuentran existe
la posibilidad de que se produzca un
nuevo brote Así que mantenemos la
cautela las autoridades siguen vigilando
A 800 personas jugando nos enfrentaba
una epidemia así desde el 2000 cuando
200 personas murieron de ébola